[Music]
and don't do it news submitted by the
Furminator a viral area51 joke prompted
a warning from the US Air Force
I hope this happens that the Horde of
people gone they all get blasted by
bullets literally what's happened there
was this Facebook event created called
storm area 51
they can't stop all of us for September
20th it was a petition to write as far
as I know it was a Facebook event that
started it so then right now there's
like two million people or like 1.6
million people being like yeah we're
gonna be there it was 1.2 when I first
saw it that's crazy there's an actual
location address was in Nevada you never
heard of area 51 I mean I've heard of I
don't but I know there was an actual
address you can go to yeah it's my
thinking like it's a top-secret
government facility with no address oh
yeah yeah yeah I mean there might not be
an address but there could be GPS
coordinates yeah so there is like a like
a Center where you can for like visitors
but not necessarily like they don't
accept people to like have a tour and
all that stuff because they're saying
that this is an actual Air Force Base
where they do testing and stuff so
they're saying like this is an open
training range for the US Air Force and
we would discourage anyone from trying
to come into the area where we trained
American armed forces the US Air Force
always stands ready to protect America
and its assets that's like I'm not
saying in a nice way you come here
we will [ __ ] roast the [ __ ] out of
pretty much that's what I'm scared of
there's these memes yeah I don't even
see the beams I don't realize that it's
like here's one me and the boys getting
back from ariseth it's [ __ ] funny who
tells chalindo ha old town right like
old town raid and then even Danny Trejo
[ __ ] that's about
why is it all Mexicans Nevada like Oh
cuz we're the ones that are the craze
but our gonna do it with the people we
have no right to know that's [ __ ]
aliens be the only one thinking too much
they get too much warning they'll hide
all the alien ship before September 20th
alright remember much that day there was
a lady with the fuller vagina know what
they were rating the thing the the
[ __ ] corn guy came no on the movie
watch at day when they raided the
building the epaulette the guy was
calling them really even have merged
made now like I survived area 51 that's
great it was the date of the raid
November 20th so the guy that made it
hadn't happened yet no the guy that made
it he made it as just a joke because he
watched the Bob Lazar and Joe Rogan Bob
yeah Bob Lazar is like a former for like
years for like five years
he's a former employee of the area 51
and he's like a whistle blower um so he
claims but yeah and then didn't in his
life but he keeps saying that it's not
area 51 he keeps saying that sector four
or something so I'm like why do people
why are people so stuck on area 51
telling people it was never there it's
here that's [ __ ] final people keep
going to be one for some reason
he's the one that let people know about
area 51 people don't even know about it
before him he's yeah yeah cuz he was
like I think in his interview he was
that I've been to area 51 that's where I
first started my job there's no aliens
there where I saw the aliens was they
took me just sector four that's where
they which is in the hill there's no
aliens there may be some people are
listening the government is like
spreading disinformation dude do you
guys think that we actually have alien
stuff thousand percent a thousand 1
million did it make you k like other
countries came out and and like opened
records and like let it let their public
no but us hasn't done it yet oh wait
what was that there's like there's UFOs
there's like actual UFOs and I think it
was I can't remember don't quote me on
this but I feel like it was Brazil in
the UK I don't
I don't remember exactly but they like
we're basically like yeah here's all
these records
they've been top secret for a long time
but we think that the public should know
what makes you so a million percent sure
I don't know because they because the
FBI released the UFO FILES and what are
they website yeah no I mean UFO just
mean aliens but UFOs yeah yeah objects
like flying saucers that there's a lot
of actual government reporting on it
like they filed a lot of unidentified
flying objects and then they released it
like five years ago so you can read all
of it or what about aliens then because
maybe he meant aliens they won't
straight up say there were aliens that
just said like okay there were UFOs
we'll give you that but that's kind of
like aliens then right because if
they're like town there's technology
that's out of this world who made them
no I don't know if they're saying that
they're just saying UFO yeah they just
don't but it's unidentified maybe it's
something that is not made by Boeing or
Northrop Grumman like something from
space that just is like fall it could be
like a backyard project that's the one
little friend right yes different
countries military spying like they just
it's unidentified but then it's also
pretty crazy to have that kind of report
that you read it's like [ __ ] these
saucers are going left and right in a Z
formation and it's 1950 something yeah
that's wild yeah and there's one I was
watching in some documentary where there
was this whole town where it was like a
big enough craft that it was casting a
shadow over their entire town and there
were so many reports about it it just
kind of got covered I remember the one
word there were lights like it was like
a string of lights that they were lit in
like South America or something yeah and
then like there was so many in the news
was like in recent times where people
had cell phones and they were like
filming it I think I remember that what
just went away
I remember seeing a tweet that was like
man I'm sort of press that there's no
aliens like they were like how do you
know anything because Trump got elected
and if they're aliens he would have sure
tweeted about it already maybe he is an
alien
he looks like one he does I don't know
man I've seen stranger things and if I
had the opportunity to go to area one
it's like what did I September 20 she's
all like an Arial 150 houses down we're
trying to go over there I'd be like nah
dude I saw [ __ ] change your things
I'm not trying to get lost and then find
some sheer muscles well that's another
dimension that's not aliens yeah what if
they like what working on that oh yeah
we don't know well maybe it does exist
as of right now but then they're working
on X accessing it kind of like a
stranger things they're saying that they
base that show off of actual report [ __ ]
like real life stuff little kid [ __ ]
throwing up a bunch of [ __ ] leech
exaggerated but like I went to the
upside down world y'all sure write a
show about it yeah man it was how boring
I wish it was like Rick and Morty cuz
the upside-down world is just looks like
a [ __ ] dark Bayou yeah Ashi yeah cool
someone who invented that laser thing
like going to different dimensions oh
yeah that'd be cool why do you think
Aryans exist um I don't think that they
don't exist like like if they happen
like if one of them lands here and
there's like news coverage I'd be like
oh [ __ ] okay but then if but I'm not
like that's not true what about all the
sightings from like all over the world
and then like the Bob Lazar guy who's
come out on Joe Rogan like I mean it
could be skewed so I'm not ever like a
hundred percent buying into one of them
cuz there's so many different sides you
know and I don't know any of them
personally so I can't be like yes that's
the [ __ ] I think that's what like if
it is or true thing cuz I'm them I'm
like the same as geo where I'm like I
feel like it's there but I don't want a
100% put my belief in it because there
is no hard truth but it does remind me
of you know that all-girls Ghostbuster
movie oh yeah in that movie they were
like literally filming the ghosts and
people are like add CG or like odds this
or whatever like what if it's being in
our face this whole time we refuse to
accept it
have you guys seen the footage though of
like there's a ton of UFO like just
footage online now it's pretty
convincing dude it's so convincing yeah
technology we have today that can make
those things love convey their Co bomb
let's say the crazy [ __ ] man yeah but
it's but when it's by like ex government
employees or something they're
disgruntled because they didn't get paid
right but there's so many hundreds of
them dude there's this thing called a
disclosure project which are like it's a
collection of all these ex government
employees that want a whistle blow and
they did it at the same time because
they were afraid to do it alone are they
alive still I don't know but this was in
the early 2000s what happened would they
find out no it's just it was just like a
lot of whistleblowers got together to
talk at the same time from different
government agencies from anywhere from
like CIA to Navy to Air Force all yeah
and then I think they had this like in
Washington DC but just one after another
like they would just talk about their
experiences with UFOs and all this [ __ ]
well there was even an astronaut - that
went to the moon no I'm strong one of
them yeah I think it was him yeah he
said like there was actual what do you
guys think about the argument where
they're like let's say there are aliens
and stuff but then the government thinks
that the regular person would trip out
too hard and cause well that's what Bob
Lazar actually said Bob Lazar said that
he if he were to go back in time he
wouldn't have made the documentary
because he's like the public right
weren't ready for it he's like I thought
the public had a right to know about
this stuff but it turns out like there's
a reason the government doesn't tell
them because they are like [ __ ] like
they don't they just go crazy and make
Facebook [ __ ] groups like that
they're really crazy yeah so he's like I
wish I never would have done it at this
point we have to invent the neuralyzer
soon
oh my god what did it call your
neuralyzer boom but then it seems like a
lot of these memes and stuff think the
alien race is like advanced technology
so like do you think because there could
be aliens but maybe they're like
primitive aliens do you think they're
primitive village I think they're like I
don't know if they I would call ever
even think primitive because they made
their way out here and they're pretty
killing it that's true yeah this is a
portal they just walked down a portal
according to Bob Lazar there's an
element that we don't have on our planet
yeah that actually there they have
discovered in the 20 years since he made
that are actually 2530 years since he
made that original documentary they've
discovered that element it just wasn't a
stable isotope isotope yeah yeah and now
they just within the past year got a
stable version of it it's only stable
for like half a second or whatever but
but they use that to power all their
machinery and ships and all yeah
vibranium that's black panther I've seen
that movie and like been space and time
and that's how they that's how they can
get from a defeat like that I know why
the government doesn't tell us cuz even
just trying to like wrap my head around
that I'm like I'm gonna just I can't
handle it yeah let me have my Instagram
leave me alone yeah like it's too
[ __ ] extreme i bob lazar i was just
interviewing Joe Rogan yeah it's the
detail T has are so [ __ ] specific yeah
it convinces me he's not trying to sell
anyone either he's just like cuz what
happened like it ruined my whole life I
wish I'd never saw anything but here's
how it works and that's how it is that's
why it doesn't pay to be a tattletale
you would have still had his dream job
yeah you would have been working with
aliens he would have known way below but
you gotta quit in the a me no he didn't
quit so they found he was taking people
up to see the UFOs which was against
like proto see the tattletale share I
don't
and then he got caught he got caught
like showing outsiders and so then he
had like people on his tail he thought
he was gonna get murdered so then he
made the documentary like they ruined
his life they made his wife like got
divorced all the kinds of you know
because he wasn't allowed to say
anything and so he made the documentary
to like save oh yeah and also to like
let the public know oh so what'd he get
like like assassinated yeah it was like
if I got assassinated like at least yeah
see this is the reason cuz they could
paint him as like a cookie yeah and then
so here's the oh [ __ ] I don't wanna ruin
everything as much well I appreciate mr.
Bob Lazar but I also feel like man you
[ __ ] up homie I feel bad for you you
should just kept the secret to himself
and play with the flying saucers oh
you're worried about feeling sorry for
him I'm just like what does that is it
would it be cool if like that yes so we
have an element they don't have and they
have elements we don't have so it's like
we start like we're trading yeah like
she's like you want some copper there
are aliens we're like a petri dish for
them like they're just doing experiments
with us Oh Hector ja I don't want to
make contact you know just like ghosts
I'm like if they're real I just don't
want to see them
think about it they love advanced group
meets another group what happens colony
yeah
you